I can't imagine what it would be like to find out
that your relative isn't actually as closely related as you once thought.
>> I thought so too, until I actually participated in 23andMe myself.
>> Wait, did you find a relative?
>> Amazingly, I discovered that I have a half
sister living all the way across the country from me.
>> Seriously?
>> Yeah. And she had been searching for her biological faimly for a long time.
And when we both participated in 23andMe, That's
how we discovered that we shared a father.
>> That's amazing.
You're a real-life example of this actually
working. It's really cool to know that
people can find their relatives even when
they're not necessarily looking. You weren't, right?
>> It's true. And I think it's time that we actually went to check
in on our friend Sterling and see
how he's doing on his biological family search.